à l'entrée de Val d'Or en Abitibi ces
petites maisons du quartier
bourg-la-marque raconte l'histoire de la
ville et celle aussi d'une certaine
gastronomie
c'est vraiment un village industriel si
on veut ça a été construit par la mine
dans des pensées 4 millions de dollars
avant même d'extraire une seconde d'or
qui ont utilisé les billes de boxe
trouvaient sur les lieux c'était
beaucoup moins cher en termes de
matériaux donc c'est une série de
maisonnettes comme ça qui sont protégées
c'est un site historique reconnu par le
gouvernement du Québec depuis 1979 donc
c'est des gens qui habitent là-dedans
[Musique]
c'est une ville qui est née dans les
années 30 donc à l'époque la crise
économique et beaucoup de gens qui ont
quitté l'Europe de l'Est pour parce
qu'aspirer une vie meilleure et qui ont
trouvé cette vie là ici et qui ont
trouvé cette vidéo sur tout dans les
mines il y en a qui sont devenus des
marchands il y en a qui sont qui ont
travaillé dans un peu dans tous les
domaines on a eu une importante
communauté
ukrainienne ici il y a encore des
témoignages de ça comme l'église
ukrainienne par exemple l'ancienne salle
ukrainienne là qui était qui a quand
même été transformé des Tchèques des
Finlandais il y en avait pas mal aussi
des Lituaniens des Bulgares des Roumains
des Russes des Polonais des Yougoslaves
c'est le cas d'ailleurs des gens qui ont
démarré la charcuterie du Nord parce
qu'à l'époque c'était la Yougoslavie
puisque partager c'est ces traditions
culinaires avec les gens disent ça se
poursuit encore aujourd'hui
à deux pas du quartier bourlamak se
trouve la charcuterie du Nord cet ancien
magasin général qu'on appelait autrefois
mngrosserie
ça commence à 1939 c'est une famille
croit qu'il y avait commencé ça ça
commence comme magasin général faisait
le saucisse dans ce sol il y a 17 ans
mes parents ont acheté de l'ancienne
propriétaire
[Musique]
une spécialité dans cette charcuterie
qui existe depuis ses débuts exacts
c'est la colle bassin exactement c'est
quoi en fait la côte bassin c'est une
saucisse à l'ail pour la neige
c'est fait d'abord
un petit peu de bœuf bien sûr
faut hacher la viande bien sûr
on met le gros apport
ça c'est un autre étape d'abord
[Musique]
donc ça c'est un mélange d'épices ça
c'est mélange d'épices exactement est-ce
qu'on peut savoir ce qu'il y a dedans
[Musique]
c'est transmissant mes parents Puiseux
ils ont pas être à moi est-ce que c'est
compliqué à faire c'est loin à faire
mais compliqué le nom c'est pas si
compliqué ça
mais il faut
après ça mais dans ma chaîne mais les
boyaux
[Musique]
fils d'ibigrants suisses allemand
Patrick aime déguster la colbassa avec
du fromage
on sent l'ail bien là
c'est bien c'est très tendre j'aime bien
la texture aussi texture fine
et ferme il n'y a pas de gros morceaux
de gras à l'intérieur donc ça c'est très
agréable ça se mange comme un peu comme
je dirais comme un jambon une tranche de
jambon très épaisse ça rappelle un peu
ça
très bon bravo
[Musique]
une tradition dans la région que Patrick
veut perpétuer je veux garder ce côté
rustique chaleureux c'est tranquille que
mon peu rentré José tu veux garder ça de
même pour moi c'est important de garder
ça puis essayer de donner son monde puis
le plus longtemps possible puis
peut-être amener le transmettre à mon
garçon
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui attendent le jour où
la colle Basso est fraîche sortie du
fumoir encore juteuse les gens
l'attendent il y a des périodes de
pointe aussi l'ouverture de la pêche
l'ouverture de la chasse la situation
géographique dans la ville fait en sorte
que c'est c'est comme le dernier arrêt
avant d'entrer dans le réserve phonique
la véranderie
oui c'est de la saucisse d'inspiration
de robes de l'Est mais ça s'est
introduit dans notre dans notre trame
puis dans notre chaîne dans notre tissu
social et c'est quelque chose qui est
typiquement Val de rien maintenant ça ça
fait partie de notre identité
[Musique]